[Musique]
au début quand ils ont annoncé ce
confinement je me suis dit oh génial je
vais pouvoir avoir du temps pour écrire
pour m'occuper de mes archives
et très vite j'ai compris que mais non
c'est un événement planétaire
il fallait que je témoigne de cet
événement en tout cas faut laisser trace
eric bouvet photographe depuis bientôt
40 ans
j'étais censé faire le premier tour des
municipales et
j'ai attrapé par la trappe à angresse
dans un camp de réfugiés
[Musique]
non je n'ai pas travaillé au début ce
qui était difficile pour moi parce que
j'avais vraiment l'impression de rater
quelque chose je m'appelle laurent je
suis photojournaliste j'ai 36 ans je
travaille plutôt dans les pays en
conflit au moyen-orient un peu d'afrique
ont fois que j'étais les greens je me
sentais invincible
[Musique]
tu es rentré d'un voyage à cuba le 16
mars
je garde un petit pied-à-terre à new
york bien que ma résidence principale
c'est à paris et le 20 mars le
gouverneur de new york romo a annoncé un
confinement général sévère et moi je
suis je suis nomades je suis
pratiquement jamais dans un sol on doit
tous que deux à trois semaines
je voyage en permanence et l'idée d'être
bloqués j'ai un peu honte de le dire
mais pour moi c'était impossible
[Musique]
mais en même temps j'étais terrifiée par
cette histoire de virus parce que moi
j'ai 65 ans maintenant autant je savais
que je faisais partie du groupe
peut-être de pinera bhl
je m'appelle peter thorne des
photographes je suis français et
américains
j'avais un voyage en haïti qui était
prévu les billets étaient déjà pris les
billets d'avion et c'était d'abord pour
moi une source de frustration de ne pas
pouvoir partir
et puis au fur et à mesure on comprenait
que le confinement allait durer j'ai été
comme beaucoup de photos ratées obligé
très hachée - fait le confinement ça m'a
obligé à travailler sur ma ville où j'ai
jamais eu l'idée de neil envie de
travailler
et là j'ai redécouvert parier et sans
kobe ne l'aurais pas fait je m'appelle
corentin fohlen je suis photographe
photojournaliste
rêver du mexique je te ra celle à la
consommation de cristal m je suis à
paris avec cette adrénaline c'était
cette énergie un peu sombre je marche
dans les rues être ma part et je me
sentais démunis à ce moment là le oui il
y avait une fragilité qui quittait
l'équipe extrême
c'est en tout cas un sentiment de
fragilité qui est extrême
antoine d'agata photographe
[Musique]
est ce que tu te souviens de l'ambiance
dans paris est ce que tu te souviens
tout petit peu de ses premières
impressions quand est sorti c'était
l'impression d'une réalité terrible où
on se réveille un matin et il ya plus
personne
qu'est ce qui t'a le plus marqué j'ai
souvenir à deux mètres trouvait place de
l'opéra un matin assez tôt il n'y avait
absolument personne ni sur la place ni
nu sur les boulevards loin y avait aucun
mouvement qu'un bruit ça m'a transporté
ça mène sa barque vraiment c'est le seul
moment où ça m'a créé une émotion aussi
forte à la fois grisante complètement
jouissive de 2,2 on a l'impression de se
retrouver sur un film sur le tournage
d'un film catastrophe
enfin même pas sur le tournage mais sur
donc en plein dans la scène parce que c
est en même temps je sentais que mon
esprit comprenais pas ce qui se passait
ils arrivent ils ne pouvaient pas
comprendre la situation de la vie de
pareils ça a été un moment qui est
marqué dans mon esprit assez dingue en
fait assez dingue
il y avait un côté assez fin du monde
mais enfin du monde assez assez chouette
finalement parce que ça me faisait un
bien fou en fait qu'est-ce que tu te
souviens de ce moment cette image on
dire vraiment un décor de cinéma
on dirait presque pas paris on dirait
plutôt rome
ou voilà on a l'impression d'être dans
le cinéma italien avec du carton pâte
cette vision touristique sans les
touristes donné à un côté un petit peu
faux petit peu fait qu à paris un peu
kitsch parfois mais en tant que grands
duos on entend le silence dans tes
photos le silence était étaient présents
j'ai croisé une fois un lapin à lapins
dans près de près des invalides
sur le trottoir qui veut emballer ses
huiles de silence était en ai pas parlé
mais c'était c'était assez incroyable
c'était irréel savez mes écouteurs je
marche en plein milieu de rue de rivoli
tout seul à faire des photos c'était
inédit et du coup en photo ça se voit
bien enfin c'est ces visuels le vide que
crée cette pandémie était intéressant
raconter en images
ça c'est bouché en temps normal periph
plein c'est donc pour ça que j'ai voulu
prendre cette photo que je pense qu'elle
est très parlante vraiment y'a pas un
chat dans cette image alors que
d'habitude en temps normal c'est
embouteillée de dengue est donc là c'est
le feu vert il ya que moi je suis seul
ici je prends cette photo normalement je
ne marque jamais sans musique
mais j'ai enlevé un moment donné mes
écouteurs et on entendait les le silence
les oiseaux les oiseaux les oiseaux et
le silence est-ce que c'est comparable à
une vie longue et je peux pas comparer
les deux ça c'est pas comparable mais
c'est ce que ça c'est quand même très
différente quand c'est de la ruine le
silence de la ruine il est fixé il est
vraiment tragique 1 s'est scellée autre
chose là moi je suis pas malheureuse
quand je prends cette photo je trouve
que c'est différent
triste au la maladie qui se propage et
pour les vies qui s'échappe mais à titre
personnel quand je fais sauce je suis
pas malheureuse du marché dans paris v
de contraire en profite presque
j'aime beaucoup paris le dimanche matin
en été vers 7 heures du matin quand il
ya personne et là je me suis retrouvé en
permanence n'importe quelle heure de la
journée dans une ville complètement vide
ça peut paraître désagréable pour
beaucoup de monde qui étaient enfermés
et mon moi de par mon métier j'ai pu
sortir
donc j'ai pu aller sur les endroits les
plus merveilleux de paris et être seul
au milieu à faire ces images ça a été
des moments de plénitude
c'est bon pour moi c'était un moment
merveilleux ça donne un effet le tirage
est très particulier dans le ciel
comment tu as réussi à faire ça alors en
fait la réalisation elle est faite m
avec donc cette chambre grand format est
logiquement on met du film de danse du
film argentique et étant donné que les
labos été fermé et que j'avais pas les
produits pour développer
j'ai émis en fait je me suis ça le
papier et c'est tout simplement des
effets de développement qui donne
l'heure ce résultat c'est ce qui faisait
ses développements c'est ça oui dans une
cuve tout simplement dans une petite
bassine comme l'amateur classique ce
virus il est complètement incolore
inodore
bref il est dans l'air sur certaines
images on a l'impression qu'ils flottent
hinx et on peut se dire ah ben ça se
passe par là
la première semaine je jetterai pas est
normal et on fait là à cause de la
nature même du virus quand elles sont
nées visibilité les images ne rendez pas
compte de cette charge de la peur de
parano de de méfiance de détention à ce
moment là on l'oublié people mais
personne ne savait vraiment à quel point
le la contamination étaient possibles et
probables
je voudrais fiac avec n'a pas été remis
qui mesure les écarts de température et
pourquoi tu as choisi de faire des
photos avec un appareil photo thermique
j'avais le sentiment que c'était pareil
pouvait rendre compte de notre niveau de
réalité le montrer autre chose que la
simple réalité tangible
mais montrer le la peur surtout qui
était on le voit dans la rigidité des
positions dans la tension et les
premières semaines les corps étaient
figées les espaces de respecter au cm en
ville
après je me demandais ce que parce que
chacun protège l'autre est ce que chacun
se protègent de l'autre est ce que est
ce que je sais est plus que que cette
réalité j'ai photographié l'intérieur
des choses du bâtiment mais des êtres
aussi en ce que tu te souviens de cette
photo c'est une petite fille est ce
qu'il ya c'est bon à mon sens c'est ce
seuil c'est cet espace à ne pas franchir
une distance qui paraît là encore
impossible à résoudre
très vite je me suis là c'est un petit
peu les
de photographier les bâtiments j'avais
du mal on recompte le la peur d'eux
2 les allemands de la chose que je ne
pouvais trouver que dans des figures
humaines en fait ce vieux couple
je trouve assez vaut la façon dont les
deux corps se fondait en un seul d'une
fatigue physique
il y en a un accablement il ya une et en
même temps ils sont ils sont proches ils
se soutiennent ils se maintiennent ils
se répondent
ils se hissent unissent presque dans une
seule forme chacun a besoin de l'autre
chacun se raccroche à l'autre
photographié la chaleur des corps c'est
une façon de toucher
oui à des choses qui secrètes et les
choses plus fragiles à des choses plus
le plus mystérieuse
[Musique]
dans les rues de new york l'ambiance
était était très lourde très très lourd
et puis dangereuse il faut bien
également se souvenir que à ce moment-là
new york était l'épicentre de virus dans
le monde entier avec plus de morts par
jour à new york d'un porto
cette photo est la première photo que
j'ai fait dans le métro new yorkais et
je voyais la terreur dans dans les yeux
de cet homme qui s'appelle harry et je
vais demander pourquoi il était dans le
métro il m'a dit j'ai pas de choix une
vie c'est je suis obligé d'aller au
travail et pour absolument que je prends
le métro l'âme à côté de lui c'était un
sdf qui vivaient dans le métro et donc
je regardais les yeux des gens et tout
le monde était qualifié
[Musique]
aussi j'étais terrifiée je suis descendu
j'étais terrifiée
pas l'idée de chopé le virus moi même et
ça c'était quelque chose de permanent
surtout pendant les jeux diraient les
premiers trois mois
mais une grande différence avec avec les
guerres que j'avais vu c'est que là avec
le virus on connaissait pas la ligne de
front l'ennemi est invisible dans la vie
interne omniprésent on pouvait pas le
voir on savait pas où c'était et donc ça
ça nous donnait un sens de vulnérabilité
de rendre plus forts croit lendemain
matin quand je me suis lavé
j'ai pris la décision de sortir tous les
jours faire des photos je me suis dit
peter tata 65 ans tu as passé ta vie
comme ça tu était pratiquement tous les
guerres du monde etc
s'il ya quelqu'un qui devait sortir en
séries c'est toi
l'ap-hp avait fait un blocus il refusait
toute entrée du journaliste parce que
évidemment au début personne connaissait
ce ce virus en savait pas où on allait
on savait pas comment ça ce ça se
passait enfin bref c'était compliqué à
gérer
j'ai proposé un sujet je leur ai dit
voilà je vais je vous propose de faire
un service différent par jour qui traite
du virus dans un hôpital différent
chaque jour et ils m'ont dit ok à ma
grande surprise les les gens se rendent
pas compte de ce que ça voulait dire
l'area les gens s'imaginent pas moi
quand je vois des gens qui me disent
ouais c'est pas grave si je le chope on
verra couvert allez faire un tour en
rien je peux vous dire que déjà il ya
une personne sur quatre camps se repent
une personne sur deux qui reçoit avec de
sacrés s'est calé quelques erreurs du
mal à en guérir
donc ça fait quand même beaucoup là on
voit il son site personnel soignant d'un
seul malade oui alors c'est pour un
transfert en général pour une salle et
on est obligé de retourner les gens
quand ils sont en rien et il faut me
suivant le poids de la personne entre
six huit voire plus de gens quoi est il
faut pas se louper quoi vous pouvez pas
dire l'europe vont tourner leur a
maintenant parce que les branchements
partout quoi et puis vous faut pas
violenté quelqu'un qui est dans le coma
il faut être très méticuleux donc
c'était ça c'était wings était une scène
impressionnante à chaque fois je répète
moi ce que je peux dire je regrette un
petit truc c'est que il aurait fallu
montrer des images plus dur je pense que
ça aurait plus d'impact auprès des gens
donc on ne voit qu'une petite partie de
ce que tu as vu oui
un moment et le corps du patient qui
bouge donc il sombra comme ça qui donc
doit se passer quelque chose forcément à
l'intérieur de ce corps et d'une
infirmière qui arrivent et qui prend la
brave le la main de de cette personne et
qui lui parlent à l'oreille et qui lui
dit ne vous inquiétez pas monsieur nous
sommes là on prend soin de vous tout va
bien et j'étais là les bras ballants
regarder cette scène voilà bon bref
c'est peut-être mal exprimé mais c'est
c'est non c'est beaucoup beaucoup
d'humanité dans cet endroit l'hôpital
moi je la boue j'ai pleuré dans mon coin
c'était c'était extrêmement touchant
c'est des images qui reste dans ton
esprit oui
est ce que tu peux parler de cette photo
en particulier d'une maman qui a
accouché et qui a été donc envoyé en réa
tout de suite qu'ils aient jamais vu son
bébé là c'est le moment où l'infirmière
apporte le bébé à la moment et on sort
de l'ascenseur et donc l'effet ben voila
quoi c'est la vie voit la naissance et
cette infirmière qui il fait ce geste et
qu'il y ait des genres et voilà c'était
émouvant
oui mais bon je suis sensible je suis un
bon client donc
[Musique]
où
g
accès inédit de suivre tout un transfert
de malades de paris à bordeaux dans un
tgv donc sanitaire une opération charlon
c'est charbon 8 et charbon 9
donc c'était gare d'austerlitz pourquoi
gare d'austerlitz parce que c'est le
seul tchèque peut faire venir une
ambulance jusqu'aux quais c'est une
question place là c'est donc deux trains
il y remplissent ça prend des heures
c est dingue parce que fall et tous les
branchements et puis la personne faut la
passer dans rez de chaussée donc du coup
faut tourner le truc à des gens qui se
mettent en dessous en portugais
c'est très intéressant visuellement et
là il ya en avant son caractère mais y
en a d'autres derrière il y en a plein
donc le train était transformée en
service de réanimation totalise accroché
tout le matériel là où il ya les bagages
où il y avait là les perfs c'était en
haut il avait enlevé les sièges ils ont
mis les brancards posées sur les sièges
l'oxygène enfin voilà tout avait sa
place d un espèce de ballet de personnel
soignant de secours dans le silence et
des gestes millimétrés quoi tout est est
restée une danse presque qui s'opérait
pour sauver ces gens qui sont des
patients me qui sont graves ou pas les
plus graves parce qu évidemment les plus
graves sont pas transportables mais sur
les 24 je crois qu'ils la plupart
étaient moi même tous été intubé et
ventilé
donc ils sont détresse respiratoire donc
là ils sont stabilisés et en l'ayant
vous envoie dans des hôpitaux à bordeaux
ou dans la région et dans la région
bordelaise pour désengorger l'île de
france
[Musique]
ça m'a touché en fait enfin la façon
connaissent leur métier mais dans ce
train c'était vraiment le ballet de tous
les corps de métier qui travaillent
ensemble pour sauver des vies il y avait
un truc de corps quand les décors et
c'était s'est déroulé alors un ballon
parfaitement mois et affirmé qu'ils
avaient aussi de sauver des vies quoi ça
m'a touché aussi et une journée
particulière moore vraiment
[Musique]
il y a deux hôpitaux où j'étais autorisé
à vivre une semaine environ sais je
dormais à l'entrée du service co vide et
j'avais accès jour et nuit je déambulais
amaguiz symbole des autorisations et
parfois je rentrais les proviseurs
deuxième chambre et la coucheuse j'avais
accès à ces moments d'intimité à ce
moment de proximité entre les soignants
des patients et et quelquefois c'était
très très beau de le voir à quel point
le le travail de ces personnes ne
consiste pas seulement à soigner ou à
nettoyer c'était déjà une tendresse
étrange immense qu'il aime beaucoup
cette image non c'est une image que
j'aime bien parce que l inverse les
relancer j'aime beaucoup cette humilité
de données fermiers et de très beaux se
trouve la position de cet homme qui qui
à genoux devant
d'où une veille dame perdue il ya plus à
l'image qu'ils ont quelque chose de
l'ordre du soin du sacré soit du magic
et cette image aussi quelque chose de
d'autres incantatoire d'ordre d'un
rituel secret mystérieux quelle que soit
la dureté des moments où la la brutalité
des situations il y avait que je très
beau dans cette proximité en fait qui
n'a manqué l'extérieur donc locales ce
qui était beau c'est lé geste c'était la
proximité c'était de la mesure dans
laquelle certains êtres koné soin d'eux
d'autres êtres assez vite je crois
c'était début avant début avril
on savait que le que le taux de
mortalité le plus élevé aux états unis
c'était dans le queens
il y avait un hôpital en particulier qui
s'appelle entre strass perreault un
dimanche matin j'ai décidé d'y aller
il faisait gris il pleuvait des cordes
est dans une période d'une demi heure
j'ai vu au moins 30 ambulances qui sont
arrivés avec des malades des collines 30
et j'ai parlé avec un ambulancier ya un
type qui s'appelle mike et je lui ai dit
comment ça se passe pour vous est
minimale parce que on ne nous donne pas
suffisamment de moyens de protection
on travaille dans le danger donc danger
mortel
gelly mais est ce que est ce que ça vous
dérange que je raconte ça il me dit mais
pas du tout il me dit je suis certain
que tous mes collègues dirais la même
chose
un mois plus tard je reçois un coup de
téléphone de ces tombes d'officiers mike
un soir et mikey me dit peter il ya un
ambulancier légendaire qui s'appelle
anthony tony tomassi qui vient de mourir
de qu'ovide moment et bien savoir si
vous serez d'accord de venir faire des
photos lors des funérailles et j'ai dit
mike ce serait un honneur pour moi de
venir
[Musique]
mike m'a téléphoné après les funérailles
de tony et il m'a dit peter on voudrait
tellement vous remercier d'avoir fait
des photos ça nous touche énormément
et là j'ai j'ai dit à mike gély mike
écoute je viens envie de te dire un truc
je suis je dit j'ai vraiment peur je lui
dis je dis pas que j'ai peur de ce virus
j'ai peur que je vais choper cette
connerie de virus et judy si ça m'arrive
je suis tout seul ici à new york je vous
dis je ne saurais même pas quoi faire je
serais pas où aller
je serai pas me défendre je suis dit est
ce que si jamais ça m'arrive que je
chope le virus est ce que est ce que je
peux t'appeler
est-ce que vous pouvez peut-être m'aider
vous êtes ambulanciers il m'a dit peter
il faut que tu saches une chose dès
maintenant tu fais partie de notre
famille et il faut pas que tu t'en face
on sort ensemble ancien occupant a
toujours de 3
[Musique]
et mike inspiron zino michael acton du
money time ce boîtier gagnent deux tomes
de sinjar dénombre que magnéto et comme
nous ils organisent un tournoi qu'il
avait une idée ou un manager vraiment
histoire un sac du quart
[Musique]
s'il ya une raison pour défaut à prendre
des risques c'est pas à cause de
l'adrénaline c'est pas à cause de deux
surtout pas de glamour c'est parce que
la vie des gens sa crainte
[Musique]
à new york c'était toujours à sept
heures du soir tout le monde sortait de
chez eux il y avait une explosion de
d'applaudissements de cris les gens
tapent aider et poêles des choses de
cuisine pour faire du bruit
as été très cathartique les gens ils
avaient besoin d'être ensemble
d'exprimer leurs émotions et moi souvent
je sortais justement de mon petit studio
à new york
socrier moi même à sept heures du soir
et je vois une infirmière en
particulière elle s'appelle erika je me
souviens que les larmes de cette femme
de 7,1 ferme je me suis dit ce sont des
larmes de nous tous ce sont ce sont des
larmes de mon entier en fait c'est
peut-être pour moi c'est la photo que
j'ai faits qui qui peut-être rassemble
le plus l'émotion profonde de cette
année des virus
[Musique]
je voudrais c'est tous les jours pendant
deux mois et demi je voudrais une façon
complètement obsessive complètement
mécanique jemeppe usées marché dans les
rues de paris donc je voudrais fier 6500
images dans les hôpitaux aussi moussa
kazim un torride avec bien sûr les
images qui reviennent qui se répète on
rentre de nouveau cauchemar
cette période j'ai dormi
dans la chance dans les bureaux de
l'agencé canapé donc
c'est me réveiller je sortais je suis
très fier et limite les plus d'horaires
et plus de
[Musique]
j'ai refusé tout mon travail consiste à
être être impliqué la façon la plus
extrême possible d'indiscrétions que le
document il ya une part du nord mme
d'empathie de conscience de solidarité
de tendresse un peu plus plein de choses
qui font que que oui je j'ai ce désir
est satisfait d'être avec l'autre ça
fait 40 ans que lui que je vis dans
cette ses principes de vie que ce soit
l'hôpital comme kokomo bordel je vis
sous les mêmes suivant la même morale
[Musique]
montrer c'est une ça fait partie de
notre métier mais je pense qu'il faut
aller au delà il faut donner à voir
il faut il faut raconter raconter c'est
déjà prendre prendre position peut pas
être photographe si si on n'est pas
engagé si on n'a pas un point de vue une
vision une idée sur la société il ya
tout autant de manière de photographier
que deux photographes je pense etc
le pense c'est fondamental qu'est ce qui
t'a le plus marqué dans cette année
passée qu'est-ce que tu n'oublieras pas
alors ce qui m'a le plus marqué une fois
passée la surprise de ces rues vides
dans paris
c'était la manière dont se vide a mis en
avant l'omniprésence des sans abri et là
d'un coup qui restait dans les rues de
paris
c'était à la fois les sans abri et et
travailleurs esclaves qui sont exploités
et qui viennent nous apporter des repas
où nous nous conduire en taxi et là
c'était quand même les deux formes de
précarité va exploser à la gueule c'est
à dire des gens qu'on pouvait appeler
les invisibles d'un coup était
totalement vue et cette misère était
totalement invisible tu te souviens de
cette photo c'est une terrasse de
brasserie à moitié couverte et il s'est
réfugié à l'intérieur
alors il est abrité mais pas vraiment un
peu des courants d'air mais pas tant que
ça il ya ce rappel à la règle que le
monde d'avant la réalité du parisien
c'est à dire le le happy hour 2 entre
16h et 21h
des tapas
il ya qui rappelle que bon c'est cet
endroit est un lieu de vie de fait que
tout le monde sortait et qu'en principe
cette personne n'a pas vraiment sa place
la manière dont les sans abri se sont
accaparés l'espace public les lieux ont
été abandonnées et que finalement
presque ce loisir de s'installer où ils
veulent et ce gain est installé à même
le trottoir en plein milieu ce qui est
fou c'est qu'il est clean dans
l'alignement d'une caméra de
surveillance
voilà les seules personnes qui ne
peuvent pas être confinée ce sont les
gens qui toute l'année sont sont
confinés dehors quoi
[Musique]
et tu continues encore cette série je
continue de travailler sur les abris des
sans abri c'est à dire comment ce que
les personnes à la rue se créent parfois
leur petit cocon leur petit monde leur
petite maison leur univers alors parfois
c'est juste un carton posé par terre
moi maintenant je repère que la manière
dont il est posé le lieu où il est posé
en fait c'est qu'une personne la veille
ou ou le soir même qui va y dormir
c'est son matelas en fait
c'est peut-être un peu banal de dire ça
ou une évidence mais chez soi aussi en
fait il ya des drames humains et on est
tellement habitués qu'on les qu'on
accepte en fait
je fais en sorte qu'on ait vu je passe
d'abord il n'a pas eu photo autour du
cou pour qu'on me voit et ensuite l'idée
c'est que après on ne me voit plus ce
qui me permet d'avoir les photos les
plus justes possibles parce que je ne
suis pas vu donc je dois être oublié par
chaque reportage ce que je fais le cdh
est discrète je préviens je me présente
ton vue ils savent que tu es là ils
savent que tu les photographies mais
c'est pas grave
puis j'aime bien être une petite souris
je suis pas là je me faufile partout je
capte un truc que j'aime bien je quand
tu n'existes pas en fait c'est vraiment
ça je ne veux pas existé je veux témoin
de quelque chose sans être là et c'est
impressionnant de voir autant de
personnes qui attendent pour une
distribution de paniers ou pas là en
fait ce qui m'intéresse aujourd'hui
c'est la détresse psychologique des gens
ça dure quand ça dure au début il ya des
civils c'est quelque chose de curieux le
confinement au début et quand ça dure la
solitude s'installe je pense que ça va
créer propos de malheur de malheureux de
gens malheureux hélas cette photo ainsi
photo en de ce coup à l'intérieur c'est
une dame qui ont été protégés puisque l
alzheimer et c'est son marines c'est
l'amour de sa vie une histoire
formidable rencontre en colonie de
vacances c'était sa monitrice j'adore
l'histoire ensemble depuis je n'ai pas
compté mais très très longtemps et donc
il ça fait longtemps qu'il n'a pas pu la
visiter parce que évidemment on ne
pouvait pas donc il la voit à travers
cette vitre au début on est un peu perdu
mais ensuite elle reconnaît et ils ont
ce geste de tendresse que j'ai trouvé
très très mignon et mais c'était dur
pour les deux elle ne comprend pas la
dame pourquoi son mari derrière une
vitre ou si elle le comprend elle va
l'oublier monde et compte du traumatisme
pour ces gens qui finissent leur vie à
travers une vitre j'ai bossé dans les
ehpad gens ne fait pas mal mais j'ai pas
fai
évidemment j'ai pas eu réussi à rentrer
là où c'était dramatique pour mais
c'était fermé total à la presse
impossible d'y rentrer et ça moi j'ai
pas pu raconter ça je m'en fous avoue
faire parce que
je pourrais pas pleurer
chez nestlé
c'est toujours la photo que j'ai pas
pris ce qui me manque le plus mais
partout et là en fait on me dit des
choses que je peux pas raconter sa
manière je pense que c'est important de
montrer en fait il ya plein d'accès
qu'on n'a pas pu avoir parce
qu'évidemment c'est c'était un
regardable 1 et fusibles peut-être mais
il faut le faire quand même même si on a
plein de photos que j'ai prises que j'ai
jamais diffusée mais il faut quand même
le faire et donc j'ai quand même fait
quelques ehpad
mais les dés heureusement il ya des gens
géniaux et des superbes maisons de
retraite que j'ai pu visiter
même si la solitude avec quand même
franchement c'est hyper dur pour ces
personnes
c'est franchement c'est triste c'est
finir sa vie dans la solitude et la
détresse psychologique
c'est quand même extrêmement dramatique
pour des gens qui ont une vie
probablement très riche et mais
l'achever sans personne lâche fait à la
solitude la plus ultime c'est j'ai
trouvé que c'était dramatique ça ça m'a
touchée comme la mort les enterrements
faire son deuil dire au revoir à ce son
bien aimé sa bien aimée son fils sa
fille sont donc sa tante
si rapidement sans mise en bière sans
soins funéraire ça je pense que les gens
étaient ce que j'ai
vu était très bouleversée de ça c'est à
dire que les gens n'avaient pas le temps
de dire au revoir à leurs proches dans
une vallée qui soit tout de suite tout
de suite évacue tout de suite donc là le
cercueil dans un ascenseur ce qui est
très surprenant parce que normalement on
ne fait pas des mises en bière chez les
jambes avec le lac au vide
il fallait en fermer tout de suite pour
pas que le virus se propage les corps
dans les cercueils
du coup ils le montrent et le décembre
aussi par l'ascenseur et la dame a dit
ne fermait pas la fermeture éclair
jusqu'au bout elle voulait pas que sa
maman presque suffoque dans le sac
mortuaire
ok elle a dit très sont ces fermes et
donc ils n'ont pas fermé la fermeture
éclair pour qu'elles puissent avoir de
l'air
[Musique]
c'est un plaisir travailler à la chambre
parce que c'est notre manière de
travailler
tu prends ton temps tu fais une vue donc
tu réfléchis bien avant ce qui est le
propre de la photographie de façon au
point de vue c'est ça c'est de réfléchir
à
c'est le cerveau qui tourne et qui
cherche à montrer ou à démontrer quelque
chose
c'est le sens de la photographie c'est
une réflexion
[Musique]
et pourquoi tu continues à les
photographier par exemple l'idylle
confiné du nord-pas-de-calais les plages
il y est je crois une histoire donc il
faut laisser trace c'est très important
en fait c'est simple mais souvent il ya
des gens qui me disent vous avez de la
chance vous vivez de votre passion sur
10 mais vous n'avez pas compris c'est
pas une passion mon job c'est un
engagement total
c'est ma vie quoi
[Musique]
fait chier tu as je le vend quoi tend à
la louche
odieux de la photo fait que mon image
soit bonne
après avoir fait par exemple évidemment
paris vide on m'a dit raté photos elles
sont noires elles sont sombres sida
comme un bon ben je vais faire mes
voisins en couleur avec un gros flash
voilà et j'ai fait mon escalier avec
tous mes voisins presque banal comme
sujet puisque c'est elle et c'est notre
vie de tous les jours
ils étaient tous confinés chez eux c'est
ça ouais on était tous confinés c'est
donc les gens étaient confinés chez eux
deux ils sont sortis sera pas de porte
et j'ai une porte qui n'est pas ouverte
parce que j'ai deux portes qui sont pas
ouvertes
il y en a un c'est la personne est parti
se réfugier à la campagne il a vécu son
confinement un campagne et l'autre
personne est décédée elle a été à
l'hôpital et dessiner mais globalement
les voisins que tu a photographié ils
ont tous le sourire
mais oui oui parce que parce que c'est
la vie quoi saignements on on se barre
on est salée il ya un truc quoi je peux
vous dire souvent quand je présente les
images que je fais de conflit déjà en
guise
je sais pas comment tu fais ou mais
comment font ces gens ou comme je dis
mais vous imaginez pas ce dont vous
pouvez être capable quand j'ai mis ça
sur les réseaux ensuite les réseaux
sociaux il fait tourner j'émets un
retour pareil extraordinaire incroyable
j'ai même eu à un moment à quelqu'un qui
me dit ils sont beaux ils sont vivants
et là et j'aurai encore un peu les
frissons à dire ça
les bras m'en sont tombés quoi pourquoi
vous avez en pleine pandémie il ya des
gens qui moi et on on était en pleines
restrictions on pouvait pas sortir on
était enfermé
c'était lourd c'était intense moi c'est
quelque chose plus que que comme je
disais tout à l'heure qui était pas
violent mais qui était dans ce qui était
profond et je les dis à mes enfants
vous verrez vous vous souviendrez de
cette période qui aura été unique dans
votre vie
donc voilà ils sont beaux ils sont
vivants ça fait du bien
je suis restée à new york pendant
pratiquement trois mois mais je suis
rentré à paris
je pense c'était le 24 ou le 25 mai et
tout de suite
aussitôt que je suis rentré mais même la
première journée je suis sorti dans la
rue pour faire des photos
un an après début de koh vide le masque
fait partie maintenant de notre monde
tout le monde connaît le masque je
trouve qu'on en fait l'expression des
yeux des gens des pianos et quelque
chose de phénoménal patimo toujours dans
mes photos on voit les yeux des gens
peut-être six semaines après mon arrivée
à paris
un jour je marchais au champ de mars pas
loin de la tour eiffel et tout d'un coup
je vois une jeune fille mais l'ania et
elle avait un petit baglama la joie de
cette jeune fille était vraiment
contagieuse après tous ces mois de
confinement et de terreur et de corps et
j'ai demandé à la jeune mère je lui dis
comment ça s'est passé pour vous le
confinement et elle m'a dit je suis
femme de ménage
je vis dans une petite chambre avec ma
fille et et pendant le confinement je ne
pouvais pas travailler tant que je ne
pouvais pas gagner ma vie et je ne
savais pas tous les jours comment on
allait manger c'était une carriole
vraiment très très difficile
alors après avoir entendu cette histoire
je suis parti et de nouveaux jets j'ai
commencé à pleurer parce que j'ai pensé
je me l'imaginé
la petite mélanie à et sa mère de 21 ans
dans cette petite chambre pendant trois
mois tout seul qui ne savaient pas
comment il allait manger tous les jours
et ça me rappelait également tous les
gens que j'avais côtoyé à new york
également souvent des gens les gens qui
nous sauver la vie les gens qui y livrer
le courrier
les gens qui travaillaient dans des
caisses temps des dents des epide dans
les épiceries les ambulanciers les
infirmières et j'espère et j'ai un peu
peur qu'on va trop vite oublier les
gestes tous ces gens dans l'eau dans le
monde
oh
mais pas une personne qui ne veut pas
être en aurait qui veut pas être
considéré c'est très important
et moi j'aime beaucoup regarder les gens
dans les yeux lors de cette année je
peux pas vous dire la quantité de froid
que que j'ai rencontré des gens dont
personne prête attention
et le fait que quelques uns s'arrêtent
pour leur parler de quelqu'un trouve que
leur vie est intéressante c'est c'est un
moment important pour eux ici un membre
important pour moi également
[Musique]
maintenant aux gouvernants de pandémie
tu as envie de photographier quoi tu
rêves de quoi je rendais dirige le rêve
de voyage et de repartir dans des
contrées plus lointaines et en même
temps j'ai l'impression que un ans
passés à travailler sur la france et sur
paris m'a donné un peu le goût de
travailler sur en bas de chez soi en
fait cette pandémie elle a quand même
permis aussi de réfléchir plaint d'
actes qu'on avait donc on se posait pas
trop de questions même de même pour un
photographe d'aller photographier
d'autres pays d'autres
est-ce que c'est pas finalement aux
photographes sur place de raconter c'est
pas plus pertinent qu'il le raconte par
le même donc ça remet en question pas
mal de deux choses
mais bon quand on est photographe le
voyage c'est quand même une des raisons
essentielles pour lequel j'ai choisi ce
métier
[Musique]
j'en ai marre assez bas âge que en fait
ça dure ça dure mais de changer de sujet
j'ai envie de sujets plus joyeux lurons
qu'un rapport a envie de faire coiffer
au poteau ses photos des photos de
banimmo mois non il ya plein de trucs
que je peux pas faire de ce que je fais
d'habitude c'est quand même pas mon
coeur de métier de travailler sur une
pandémie après moi je trouve que tout
est intéressant et tout ce qui s'écrit
ce qui s'inscrit dans l'histoire est
intéressant mais je me rende envie de
passer à autre chose et donc quelles
photos tu aimerais faire nos principes
tout était comme à vente
si tout était fini qu'est-ce que tu
rêverais de faire juste maintenant non
mais là ça va paraître bizarre mais
j'aimerais vraiment en irak
[Musique]
je
ce que je voulais faire ça serait d'une
banalité ça se fait photographier c'est
toutes ces terrasses de café pleines
ça serait pas mal mais ça serait bien ça
serait bien
qu'est ce qui est important c'est les
gens que je photographie tout ce soit
une femme qui porte cette api de grozny
où que ce soit à mes voisins qui vient
de me dire ce qu'ils pensaient du
confinement dans la série des voisins
c'est pareil ces gens vont rester pour
l'histoire est ce que dans cent ans il
sera encore là ils seront en photo
encore
j'ai mis beaucoup de temps à m'en
remettre et
donc cette période m'a abîmé laissé des
traces je suis fatigué de la séparation
des corps de la distance de la main
fermement de l'autre mais ça a été une
responsabilité ça a été un privilège de
vivre au coeur de ce moment on pense
souvent que le qu'il faut être fort
expérimenté et dans mon expérience c'est
le contraire je sais je m'évertue
restait fragile restait à la merci de ce
graphique
donc oui la fragilité est un élément
essentiel dans le fonctionnement
photographique et dans la vie
cette année qui qui nous a changé la vie
et je crois que on n'est pas prêt de
comprendre comment complètement
je sais que c'est une année qui m'a
changé la vie je sais que c'est une
année où probablement plus que jamais je
ressens vraiment la seule chose qui nous
donne le pouvoir dans la vie c'est
l'amour mais en fait il n'ya que
l'amitié l'amour la tendresse
l'affection la sincérité et l'honnêteté
qui compte
[Musique]